the reason i've always been more brand
than digital sales is digital sales
changes you're living it right now i'm
always going to push brand and i'm very
bullish about this mascot thing i think
every small business on earth should
have a mascot including b2b this portion
is like with me so i think this is when
you need to get selfish like you need to
ask your question
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this is the television
and the television is the radio
the 40s [ __ ]
jim norman this is my sidekick dakota uh
we met at the burns bayer thing not too
long ago i have the sit with me app um
helping servers and partners connect
with their best customers i remember
good to see you
hey hey brother good to see you again
uh spanking founder of a company called
ad zombies who are not scaled
copywriting service we write towards the
sale everything for
about 40 000 clients
that's awesome
hey gary uh tom lehrer i
run a company called expedia interaction
marketing we are a 500 seat
employee call center outsourcer located
here in the states and not here d.a
that's awesome how did you get that uh
started as a startup i mean the hoodie
oh just paid 1400 bucks on ebay
[Music]
i didn't think your fingers were that
fast
my wife is still
happy about it
it's a pleasure
jason borenoi uh i run an agency called
jport media i launched a coaching
program and i have a podcast called
perfectly known
it's awesome
dave carroll uh doe marketing we all
make direct mail make sure it has
something
awesome pleasure michael munsterman
monster automotive group
joy hi joy it's good to see you hey gary
how's it going well get go yes just a
few minutes ago yes
check it out did you see what it was
johnny walker
very cool
thank you for that
thank you talk to the four yep i got a
good i got great context yeah and i've
got dakota here now this
[Laughter]
i get it i get it it's amazing uh he
does all of our content okay we're only
five months in yeah um a lot of what we
did was just like
is this a good idea will it work yeah um
do do servers it's kind of a big shift
or servers and bartenders willing to
start instead of saying
remember when i worked or hey do you
want my cell phone number yep i remember
i remember everything about our talk um
so my question kind of becomes is what
should i do next steps as far as growing
the business and not wanting to develop
the rest of the features that are in my
head i think you have to have more
critical scale on the core feature the
biggest mistake people make is try to
add features when
they're this young
so keep with the mvp there's you know
there's a handful of bugs and little
things yeah you gotta fix it yeah you
gotta
to that point right like first get all
the bugs out
and get critical scale in the core
feature you know
people get very feature
like fancy before they've got the thing
going
right like to me you've got to have 25
000
servers on the platform active i'm
talking once a month i've engaged with
the app
before you even like think about the
next thing
i've seen so many people misstep in
appland by adding thinking that adding
things like adding things makes things
worse
simplicity is always the champion
and people don't get traction on
whatever they have or they're impatient
or they haven't given enough time they
start putting all their energy on adding
features when what 100
of what you should be doing is getting
people on the platform
i know you've been doing those what i
would also do is i would go to search on
instagram search bartender bartending
all that literally follow every single
bartender in the country and once they
follow you back dm them and start trying
to build
your business is in full hand-to-hand
combat
how do you like the idea of and it's
kind of a question but going to
management that whole sales and say hey
would you like to have 37 sales people
helping fill the restaurant during lunch
we talked about that if you if you stay
the course of what we talked about the
other day of like trying not to convince
them the difference between me and my
dad when i told you
too many restaurant tours
are going to think that you're going to
lead to them losing people
but 25 will see the value so the answer
is a hundred percent
it's how you scale
if you go to 100 restaurants and knock
on doors
and get 25 to say yes that's 25 times 3
to 35 servers
i just think you're gonna need to fight
on two fronts direct to bartenders
direct to servers right obviously we
talked about the expansion of you know
probably sit with me but like
sit with me also i think works for
hairdressers and barbers right so i
think you have to fall on two fronts the
b to b the b to b to c and the b to c
the b to c is going to the individuals
who do it and the b to b to c is going
to the establishments who then will sell
to their people i just know small
businesses well i just think a lot of
them are going to be scared for sure
right
you see it already right yeah it's just
three people above
any kind of commitment yeah and just
like even if you get directly to the
owner in a small business like hey
do you want your servers to use this app
like
a lot of them are just going to go down
the path of like [ __ ] karen's my best
she's going to get a clientele and she's
going to leverage that against me
so i just think you have to be really
prepared for that i think you have to
you just have to succumb to like it's
gonna be two out of ten and that's okay
because two out of ten is good because
especially i would probably start with
places that are bigger
because if you're gonna go two for ten
you'd rather go two for ten that have 30
servers each then 2 for 10 that have two
servers right so i would think about
scale as well
i've got one that i think you'll you'll
like and i'm trying to figure out the
right way to do it i've created with a
with a good friend of mine who's an
amazing muralist
around louisville mainly but he's got
probably 70 murals around the country
super talented hates social media has
never put his stuff out there
he's a college friend an older man of
mine and so we've created an nft project
i actually i like you i drew one first
i'm a terrible artist
myself but drew something
how would you integrate
an nft project to
help build this community and i'm all
for educating i've been you know since
you started talking about it you did my
80 hours of homework and paid a lot of
attention no expert but as much as
people can know
so how would you integrate that into
maybe getting the server community
involved in yeah i would probably start
a discord for this community
i would probably run ads
specifically towards people in the
service industry and say do you want to
learn about nfts i'm
no expert but i'm pretty far along
i think the thing that most people
struggle with when they're running a
business is separating the giving from
the thing that they're hoping happenings
when you give
i think the reason i wrote jab jab jab
right hook
and the reason i have to like i'm
actually thinking about getting back
into that content i think people
go much closer to manipulation than
value with karma when they do this i
think the thing that separates me is
when i do content i'm in content mode
i just don't i don't even like from day
one wine library tv episode one that i
thought i was i i haven't told this
story in a long time i thought i was
doing qvc in the week that wine library
tv was building in my head i'm like i'm
gonna do qvc on youtube this thing
youtube's gonna be big the second the
camera went on
i did
i did a totally different show i did
martha's you know stuart i just like i
something about the camera made me say
[ __ ] i don't feel comfortable selling
on this show because it's gonna be a
show that really is an infomercial if i
do it this way [ __ ] it let me just be
wine spectator and robert parker i'm
just gonna review this [ __ ] wine
which is radical as [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
selling this stuff downstairs
and i'm in my office saying this is
garbage wine and like like literally
like the first six months the company
really genuinely actually thought i'd
lost my mind okay you have to remember i
was six at a different time the internet
like none of this existed yet they're
like what are you doing
and i'm like
i'm doing a show
that's i remember that was my answer i
wasn't really even sure how i answered
it now i just recalled like doing a show
and on that show it's got to be the show
and what i learned through that process
was by doing that you actually gain
relationships and with relationships you
then have opportunities if you choose to
create events and so i think
i think for a lot of you which is
obviously why i always want the context
overall up front
like doing doing content that is not a
lead gen to conversion
is an incredibly foreign mindset
to most people
and i think it's exactly where all the
action is
give give give
and then ask instead of have some sort
of concoction that is fake give with the
hope of taking those are two very
different frameworks i think that's
what's worked for me and the things that
i've observed have worked for others
makes sense
let's just provide value to this
community maybe from a how do you grow
your brand how do you play with nfts how
do you grow your career how like you
know just drop some uncle [ __ ] on them
build build build build and then just by
i mean i think the right hook sits in
your bio
i mean there was years there where i
really besides a book had nothing
and
you know just it's in the bio i mean i
don't
i
i think i leave a lot of sales on the
table for our businesses at vayner x
for i mean even me friends
i mean if you really analyze my social
content
i'm not looking to sell a lot in
comparison to how much i believe in it
and how well i think that would go
i just it's just not the framework and i
think that's where people are struggling
with social content they make content
with always the intent of it being an ad
which is the thing that nobody wants to
watch
one thing i've noticed in this group
you know i'm uh we've got car sales
we've got print ads
um you know and and i've got tipping
there's some pretty like thing there's
things in there that people just can't
stand they think they have a bad outlook
on car sales people
tipping it's been amazing
we use car salesmen right
we've talked about that before like
there's people that get fired up in my
comments about you shouldn't tip you
know it's
it's not my job to pay which is bananas
right i mean that that's noise right
people you know people don't like paper
people don't like marketing people don't
like nfts how would you recommend
leaning into i wouldn't say that
i would yeah i mean i would recommend
first of all
you only have so much time and energy
so i'm sure there's something very
clever and do i think you could make a
video that gets four million views on
tick tock on making an inside joke
around tipping culture i do
do i think that's the best use of your
time i don't i think what i would do if
i was your if i was the third person on
this team i would say three times a week
for nine to 11 hours a day we dm every
bartender on earth
i think the thing that people lose early
on is how much dirt work it really is
people are usually trying to get to 201
and 301
you have a clear path
bartenders at scale live on instagram
dm them all
all of them
every one of them
you know what i mean same for you guys
you literally i can literally right now
go to where your two locations the exact
city we're in
i can literally type that in right now
in location on instagram and see every
person that posts and that accepts zip
code and could leave a comment and say
that's cute that's cool that was funny
that's outrageous that's amazing
you just become part of the community
you can do that four hours a day on a
location
and it's depth
[Music]
you just become part of the community
your logo is showing up in every [ __ ]
comment on every single post
in your city
and if you don't fully mail it in i'm
just saying
if you actually look at it and try to
work like you know what's great i mean i
know this because this is what i was
doing for wine library you know some of
these people
you know like you leave something like
what you think of the coleslaw yesterday
they'll just think that's crazy you give
a [ __ ] you know
they're moving yep
do you know do you want people who don't
tip on your app no what have you just
said like here's a tip if you don't tip
this isn't for you oh we did yeah like
that type though isn't it yeah
cool let's move on spanky all right
let's introduce your son too it's
interesting is where he came all the way
from arizona got out of college for a
few days and wanted to see garyvee so
yeah
second oldest son mason mason it's good
to see you brother
um good kid
two of my five are good
that's a solid percentage
almost all of them uh so so right before
cobin i had started kind of creating
some division between
my personal brand and the business just
to kind of create a little yeah i
remember i think i ran into somewhere
right you brought that up yeah yeah and
uh and big deal and i had a conversation
about it so i created some separation
then covered yet
and
i was sick for
about six months you were yeah [ __ ]
i so i was dark i wasn't online of
course i kind of went invisible
same time ios 14 happens all the gdrp
regulations happen yep
and
if you looked at the top of oh and then
right after i healed recovered from
coping
i had put off having a rotator cuff
repair rotator cuff labor bicycle so
this all got done so 2020 was a
completely lost year
our top of funnel collapsed
completely like
we went from six
and six thousand a day a new business to
six thousand a month yeah
now we still have great retention on our
on ourselves yeah but your clients but
your cac model broke right it broke
and i'm trying to figure out how to
repair it and i don't want to get
desperate and start trolling for sales
but i i am trying i have been and dave
and i know each other and jason i know
each other i'm trying to figure out for
months how to
fix it well you know was it was it super
retargeting like super hardcore dr we
yeah we were we were able to take that
top of funnel
and like because 97 of our first touch
comes through this yeah but all of our
transactions come through this yeah and
so we lost the ability to to retarget
them yep and and that in europe
simultaneously it was like the perfect
[ __ ] story yep
well look i mean you know one of the
things that i talk a lot about inside of
vayner and kind of like in general is
shit's always going to change
and obviously the timing of those things
changing
with you having to be kind of out of
commission
is a compounding effect when the jockey
is on the sidelines and the race changes
shit's gonna get hairy um and
and
you know i think i think
much like
where you were when we first crossed
pass you have to reinvent a wheel that
works
the problem for a lot of marketers is
the last era was very technical and math
this next era is going to be much more
art and branding i love it because i
like that more
i don't like it because i know a lot of
people are going to not do as well
because it's harder i'm empathetic to
that but you know i think i think the
first thing you've got to get
uncomfortably serious about is tick tock
you're going to have to figure it out
whether it's you the human or some other
human variable or a character
you is a great player i would highly
recommend for all of you to debate the
concept of the mascot so i believe this
next decade of interest graph social
media
is going to
create an opportunity for a lot of
people to lean into the mascot similar
to 1950s to 70s television
so we all kind of got a sense of the
personal brand you're living it i'm
living it people are living in this room
i'm pretty hot on the scalability of
mascots
so if you think about metlife paying you
know peanuts a fortune to borrow snoopy
or what you see from the geico lizard on
a commoditized business like insurance
i i'm very hot on that and
one who is good at building a personal
brand
can also be good in my opinion of being
the jim henson
to the muppet
something worth debating i know it's a
left field thing but no different than
us
all when i first was doing this
it was crazy like a person following you
around everyone thought it was asinine
it was [ __ ] i mean the judgment i had
inside my own company
who the [ __ ] do you think you are and i
was empathetic i understood but i knew
it was going to happen
so people started having jobs where they
were filming people like things changed
right i think the same thing's about to
happen with animation claymation
puppeteering
and i think you know with ar and nfts
uh you know i think some of the people
here should really debate creating a
mascot
and scaling the mascot and i think a
mascot on tick tock scales okay so so
let's let's talk personal brand versus
the zombie brands right and the cool
thing is you can just do both okay
so like the zombie brand should have a
zombie okay like that's easy right like
that's not even hard like clearly you
need a song like most companies are like
what am i gonna do you're like i don't
know like a zombie you know so and we've
got some cool artwork but i think i
think you really need to take a step
back and be like [ __ ] it we'll never be
you know i don't know how when you
thought about building personal brand
how you thought about like where that
was going to end up but like it's not
like you have to it's not like you have
to create [ __ ] ronald mcdonald if you
just create a zombie
that is effective to get your cac and
ltv up in the next 24 months you'll be
just fine right and unlike retargeting
in ios 15
we still know who the [ __ ] the trixx
rabbit is we still know who captain
crunch is you still know who scooby-doo
is people underestimate the value of
brand the reason i've always been more
brand than digital sales is digital
sales changes you're living it right now
i had email open rates of 93
you know like [ __ ] changes i was buying
the word wine on google for five cents
that's just that doesn't work anymore
right so
i'm always going to push brand and i'm
very bullish about this mascot thing
very i think every small business on
earth should have a mascot so he started
including b to b and then covet happened
and i'm like
and i called it not afraid to go back to
dewey you know
you have no choice right but i'm not i'm
not um what's the word you always use
romantic yeah you don't mind yeah you're
a scrapper right
and so i'm comfortable doing that yeah
but holy [ __ ] it's scary like
it's less scary it's it's you know funny
it's less scary it's more like [ __ ] you
know it's kind of like one but you know
what i mean it's not scary you're not
scared no it's more like [ __ ] again
but this time i'm trying to push you
down the path of
something that is so hard to take away
you know when everyone's like well easy
for you gary your nft problem like you
mean the thing i earned like you had a
community i'm like i earned it
like people like you your nft project
dude mine's not i'm like you're 20.
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
know what i mean like and that's how i
think about brand right when you get
funnels
when you get arbitrage math
you've
earned it but you've also put yourself
in a vulnerable spot of letting somebody
else control your fate apple [ __ ] you
right
because they wanted to [ __ ] facebook and
google right you were just just you were
just collateral you were just collateral
damage
yeah joe how much on that one yeah two
minutes can i defer the last two minutes
to myself 100 yeah
okay well recently i had this idea it's
kind of
a hub i guess you could call it for
athletes and brands they can't like meet
connect with each other and so he's kind
of helped me put it all together
but one of the things i've been trying
to figure out is how do you build the
value for an athlete for the brand well
i didn't yeah i think more hubs aka what
you're describing two-way marketplace is
the hardest business to build in the
world which is why when they're built
they're worth a fortune
uber ebay
these things are incredibly challenging
i start with that sentence because i
want to make sure you're in right
mindset of how hard it is to balance the
reason they're hard is because you have
to balance both sides so equally and so
effectively that they work because when
one is off kilter people bail if you get
87 athletes and there's no money on
there lily [ __ ] you
if you get brands there's no like you
understand
it's a really hardcore patience game you
also have to make sure you're actually
solving a problem
so brands that are small are able to dm
bengals there's agents there's marketing
firms like excel so
i think
i think it's a very big challenge what
you just laid out in a couple sentences
but the answer historically is to make
both sides of the marketplace have
enough value in concurrency that you're
able to create stickiness
does that make sense yeah it's a really
big challenge and sometimes
i think people try to build things that
the problems already solved
and i'm always worried when
um
what was that thing that meg whitman and
jeffrey katzenberg quibby
i remember looking at quibby do you guys
know what quibby is it was like a pretty
famous crash and burn of like a trillion
dollars it was supposed to be like i
mean it was jeffrey katzen he's a beast
and meg when b i mean it was like the a
team all the people they hired were like
people that i thought were the best in
silicon valley in hollywood
and they were gonna build this thing
called quibby which was an ott for short
form content
and i remember looking at it and i was
like you mean youtube
and and
and yet they overspent on making shows
for like they were spent they were
paying production companies the same
amount of money netflix was paying for
long form for five-minute shows
that were pretty much
not exactly but like [ __ ] youtube was i
remember i kept telling everybody i'm
like youtube scratching that itch
youtube is scratching that itch
and so i want to just make sure or like
online dating right a lot of online
dating companies right now are trying to
figure out their way i'm like it's
called instagram dm
like sometimes things are solving the
problem
so just make sure that when you think
about it create something unique enough
that is solving a problem that doesn't
exist in different ways already
does that make sense
you know what i mean yeah ask a lot of
questions too and i also think smbs are
really good the biggest brands in the
world they go through funnels that look
like this
right they're like hey we're doing a
national campaign who should that that's
what they're comfortable with smbs are
just trying to get the best deal they
can right my dad you guys right a lot of
we're just trying so
think about the s
i would highly recommend starting with
smbs and athletes because you can get
both in that scenario it's gonna be hard
to get dr pepper to give a [ __ ] you know
you're gonna have to go through 100
gatekeepers but getting local businesses
like start where you are if that's zona
it's local businesses [ __ ] red devils
and wildcats like go right
small business
yeah absolutely let's get it gary just
quick i'm a straight d friends nerd um
but when you're before dawn can we have
the perfect crazy cat wow can we can you
sign it yeah so
that's the diamond i'll bring it down
[ __ ] you pulled it or you bought it
bought it from an ebay like you're
i know how the arbitrage works
you sign that no ut
go ahead fire away while i do this all
right um
i won't have a macro i want the weird
visionary gary okay um
i want to kind of have just a macro
conversation so i don't know a contact
center um
we work for brands do customer support
for them
and like that i know how to do this
go ahead
i'm listening that's the best thing i
learned so far
how to get cards out yeah that's a lot
of years of card shows thank you you're
welcome
um
and so
you know we work for companies like
melissa which is a toy town i know i
deal with a lot of you know financial
services brands and
you know people talk about call centers
they they think it's just like a button
a seat in some agent but it's a pretty
high-tech thing right yeah there's
speech analytics and natural language
processing and all this stuff so
i want to move and i'm so now really
kind of because of you really moved into
this web 3.0 and i want to first just
have a quick conversation on
where you see kind of customer support
how web 3.0 can affect that like i know
from you know from a loyalty standpoint
from access like i kind of get all that
one of the things that we're doing and
just kind of wanted your opinion on this
too is
we have our internal developers and then
we have two outside groups that are
developing like i don't want to say the
first and maybe somebody else is doing
it but the first
virtual reality contact center right
just a proof of concept but basically
how how's the vr going to be consumed so
on on desktop so currently like let's
just say hypothetically you put on your
oculus but nobody will do that i think
it's proven concept i don't think it's a
viable product yeah
um but basically go into an office and
there's six offices and one is password
reset and shipping problems and it
basically be able to go i think that is
like
12 years away
right
i mean 12 years away from the standpoint
of i think being a profitable
actionable business
um but the number one mistake people
make when there's something big looming
is timing
first of all it's going to be b to c
first before it's b to b right think
about who's going to do that
you barely we don't have b2b people
making content on linkedin do you think
though even from how the [ __ ] am i going
to get somebody yeah
to kind of show the forwardness of the
company right like are you looking for
an exit
so if you're telling me hey gary i want
to do this because i think for a
potential buyer if they're going to say
whoa these these guys and gals are
pushing it so much more in the industry
we need to be on board with them i do
think there's validity to that argument
you got to be careful with timing on
that front because it might hurt you if
it's super delusional
but yes i think you're on to something
there i do i do always think
if you're trying to sell to a private
equity firm or trying to do an m a
that the person in the room that's most
progressive in technology does
oftentimes have the potential to have
some leverage in in an acquisition
so where i mean where do you see this
this the the customer experience space
right like
um you know really like servicing
customers was with what
3.
the earliest thing we'll see is
transparency and data
so i think what the blockchain does is
give the potential for public data
which i think creates
silly little things believe it or not
that look like
knowing how many minutes to the second
you actually are going to be on hold
actually
like and and seeing like no no i'm not
you know how we get mad when we don't
even know the truth behind it we're like
i'm like i'm on hold and like like just
knowing that you can see other people
being taken in the queue because it's
public
servers not private servers we'll just
give you peace of mind we're like look
i'm 17th in line it's a very sub notice
how it's a very subtle thing but it's a
real application gary maybe to tag on
out to do uh like uh an nft
drop for a brand that basically says
you're uh you know you're a high-end
customer so when you do call in you go
to the front of a lot that's for damn
sure the question is
for what kind of business and how early
are we actually in nft land right right
now nft land
is predominantly driven by speculation
and greed
but that's the same thing that drove
internet stocks in 96 so that's not my
concern i can go to sleep at night every
day i tell everybody 99 of projects are
going to zero when everything goes to
zero everyone's going to blame me
because i'm the poster child of nfts and
i'm going to bring out 83 000 receipts
and be like i told you 99
we're going to zero so what i'd be
concerned about right now is you're
thinking about scaled
consumer execution
and we're still five years away from
that truly like we are
pretty you're just so deep i want this
so like i want everything
i get it but that's when people lose
money yeah
when you want to do something versus you
reacting to what they're doing right is
the most important delta in the world
i want a lot of things how does that how
does that correlate to being first to be
delusional
um
it's it's in the delta of how many
people are actually doing the thing
i was very aware of i bought a theorem
in 2016.
i didn't say outside of a couple videos
i had to bring up some because people
were like you [ __ ] look fine here's
the receipt here's me in 2017 saying
this outside of me digging up that [ __ ]
in my our archives i didn't say much
about it because i was just watching
right right and then i felt in december
on the back of nba top shot and a little
bit of crypto punk stuff going on
finally did the homework i was like oh
[ __ ] it's close
and and it got and it happened
real quick tom before we move on from
you i want to make sure gary understands
a bit of context as we were talking
earlier about your personal brand your
business you were mentioning you want to
be number one in your niche right and a
couple of cool factors that we've
discovered along the way is number one
all of your call center staff is based
in america i don't know if that's a
thing yet i think i think it's a real
thing i would pound the [ __ ] out of
facebook middle america in perpetuity
there's an unbelievable amount of people
that will make the decision on that does
that mean i never have my phone on i'm
so funny another thing that i think is
interesting about his business because
it's a call center by nate one second i
apologize
nick i'm in four d's
everybody okay
you need something
okay i'll call you later later
is um because he's got such an
interesting opportunity on tick tock
because his call center there's a lot of
people talking about call center
complaints and stuff like that on the
platform stitching do weddings stuff
like that could be it's really
interesting
if you want to own that knee yeah
that space
when i when i saw that sports cards were
going to blow up
i spent nine months
nine months
making sure that i wasn't forcing it
because i like sports cards right
you're taking something you love and
you're interested in and trying to speed
it up in your business and it's and you
need to be careful of that but good god
one more minute yeah so i guess one of
the things that's television that i am
doing that i can do is i do have a
podcast have a niche pretty large niche
following which is awesome and it's
called advice from a call center geek i
love that um and i'm just gonna do a 30
token free should absolutely do that
that's scratching your that's fun right
that's keeping the juices going right
that's not strategically aligning your
vision towards vr call centers right
that's two very different things that's
great yeah you should definitely do that
because you'll be pumped and it's good
for you to taste it right to learn how
to a hundred thousand percent
okay cool poor annoying let's go all
right um so question one
last year we spoke podcast number two
you said june we were we're in contact
you said june but in your defense you
didn't say what year
we're doing
early or late depending on how you want
to look at it but i want to make sure
that i take the opportunity to lock down
podcast number two let's do it i'm happy
to do it oh my god yep perfect okay um
from the
business side of things 2039
uh when we last spoke i was telling you
i was building an agency and i asked you
how would you build an agency you told
me god no i wouldn't and
can you stop um
i did not listen to you good built an
agency good for you um
but i did take your advice on not
wanting to build a huge 800 person
agency i stayed lean yep um
specializing what we specialize in
scaling 70 figure brands um making the
money 30 to 40 margins that's great so
pretty pretty impressive on that end
cope it happened ios happened
you told me what you warned me about
with building an agency happened which
was i'm not the guy anymore the
strategy's gone i now have a team that
does everything so what do i do
um
but i love the education side so when
ios happened i love the branding side
i'm a marketer more than a more than i'm
a button pusher inside the platforms so
i understood all these things i spent a
lot of time going on back on with
clients and educating them through the
process
love the coaching aspect of them so i
decided i was going to monetize my
knowledge my systems
all that in the space and i started a
group coaching program
called market domination
and
we're now two months in
nine members
uh fifteen thousand dollar price point
uh per year yeah per year yep uh that's
the beta
i'll probably increase
it yeah it's less about that i just
wanted the context yeah yeah so i guess
my question isn't
what the content or how i could help the
people i'm pretty good yeah you know
your craft i'm pretty clear on that it's
more i guess the who
right and i guess i wanted to jump
inside your brain that when you're
making content when you're trying to
push something um
what's your heuristics what's your
process when it comes to refining your
message when people want to work with
agency whatever it is and putting out
content that actually
baits the people
you want to work with the
thing that everything that's built on
with me is based on the fact that i do
96 listening even though the world
thinks i'm talking all the time
so
creating
scenarios that allow you to listen
because you'll know the answer way
faster than i will it'll be right there
in your messages
so
for example back to the whole jab jab
right hook thing
maybe you do i think you would crush i
know you would crush with a the thing
that people always get confused about
when they're selling their smarts
is they don't want to give away things
for free when giving away things for
free is the way you sell more stuff
so i would if i were you i would do a
weekly two-hour live
across all platforms use stream yard and
put it on all your platforms even if
you're tiny right now even if you have
nine followers on your facebook fan page
because you never set one up from
facebook to linkedin to twitter
youtube and do a live two hours a week
q a show about marketing and you start
with i mean
dude i was that you know like everyone's
got such a struggle with like you know
going back or going but like if there's
seven listeners the first week it
doesn't matter because the content saves
yeah again it's not the going back that
bothers me but i believe that but the
answer to your question is you got to
get the questions
if you get the questions
you'll know what to make in the content
because like the who part is really a
tough question
well the who's the who i deal with
plumbers i deal with econ owners like
it's who is everyone yeah exactly well
that's a good that's a weird thing no
people know people struggle with that i
understand what you're saying
this is a classic example of the
philosophy sounds better than the
reality the philosophy of like target
you're on like no he like
you're the world is in play
right the world's in play for you
i think what's really good is the way
social networks are now built there's so
much entrepreneurship in those pipes
that if you live there they're there
there's just a lot of people
that are doing 250 000 to 2 million a
year in revenue that can afford 15 000 a
year to dominate their marketing you
just don't know if it's a tattoo artist
with two parlors in nevada or if it's
you know somebody who's got a b2b
company doing 100 million like it's all
kind of like there
i think it's more about do you make
contextual creative for the platform
like do you know how to make a tick tock
that people actually want to watch that
may lead to virality that leads to lead
gen do you know how to make content on
linkedin that works which is why i want
to put you in a position to answer
questions because from the questions
you'll figure out the answers
um
you don't consume a lot but everyone
here consumes you consumes other people
the buzzword is authenticity right when
you're putting out content be authentic
be authentic but i mean
i don't really know what i think it
means anymore when you start consuming
so much content how do you then
you know that's a good question how do
you then break off who you are right
right
that's a real that's a really great
question you know i think just the fact
that you're even asking that question
already has you 90 of the way there
means you're gonna fight for it along
the way
i consume more content than everybody i
just consume it from the people directly
not a middle man or woman in between
so when i say don't consume it's i don't
need
tim ferriss or ryan holiday
or or oprah or anything in between i
just need you at the second the reason
my content works so well is i have a
leading pulse on [ __ ] because i'm
reading and at this point i'm at such
scale that i'm getting a lot of optics
like the thought that rich kids were
upset because they subconsciously were
mad at their parents for paying for
everything was very foreign to me that's
not how i grew up
but it became some of the most important
content i've ever made for parents and
25 year olds
that was just by reading them right and
so you just gotta you know
in 2014 when i came out of content
retirement i don't talk a lot about not
making a lot of content from 11 to 14.
it was kind of the biggest gap since
2006 for me because i was building
vayner and everything was going into
that
um
i started with the askgaryvee show
that was my first re-entrance post wine
library tv notice what it was called
notice what it was i needed to get the
insights my biggest beer is oh another
gallery
and i i'm a business owner before guru
yeah and now you have so many people
take one of them yeah take it from
somebody who like legitimately is like a
real [ __ ] businessman and
a shocking percentage of the world
thinks is a motivational speaker and a
guru
it doesn't matter
if you're a real business person then
you're a real business person
yeah i mean there's people who think i'm
a [ __ ] scam artist you know what
devastating that is people are going to
see what they want to see i just i worry
about my own line being blurred right
yeah i think that's right i'm like is
that really me or is that me trying to
be well that's where i think
like the advice we talked about earlier
was the most important forget about you
trying to be anything if you sit down
and you're like how can i help people
so i love this like i don't have a gear
right now other than like listening
intently trying to give the right
[ __ ] answers to the best of my
ability on intuition and pattern
recognition and then you leave yeah but
that's the best thing i learned from you
when i do speaking events i sit there
and say i'll talk for 10 minutes the
rest i want to do is q a because good
that's where i thrive yeah i think
that's great i think you should scale
that i think you should do a q a show on
linkedin and pound it in oblivion
there's not enough live content on
linkedin you'll the algorithm will
reward you perfect thank you podcast in
2015
for me uh first apology i didn't
introduce connor i was so excited connor
such a pleasure
that's right joe made a rule of like one
person i think that was more on joe
um
my question is leading towards scale so
uh
we've been in business three years we
started selling subscriptions about
eight months ago we got to a 160 000 a
monthly recurring revenue in eight
months
questions what's subscription uh so we
sell a subscription to our direct mail
platform the software that we built got
it
so it's a sas product
yeah so i just the subscription
shop until you're [ __ ] crazy that's
not the plan at all fulfillment partners
we've tried all the other [ __ ]
they're a piece of equipment they have
manuals we hired humans to put it all
together
so we do it all in-house yep
huge in home service right now so my
background i have a cleaning company
we've had for 12 years we leveraged that
a lot i've been doing the public
speaking the trade shows come out with
products in that space and it's working
but we [ __ ] hate it it's painful so
like
the mom and pop the customer service
it's the same [ __ ] compensation from
chuck in the truck who started yesterday
all the way up to a 500 million dollar
looking business like there's no
predictability yep so looking towards
scale we want to sell the company for
500 million by the time we turn 40
that's in three years i would tell you
right off the bat the first thing about
that sentence is
when i've noticed when entrepreneurs
make those kind of ideologies they dig
into it
and they tend to make mistakes when they
have something good because of some
arbitrary number like why not 750
million by the time you're 30 because we
keep putting a number to it it's got to
keep going up
i get that just keeping just make sure
you have a good relationship with it i
think that number yeah can it change of
course that that sounds like a good
relationship with it okay i just have
noticed a lot of people make these crazy
numbers like when i'm 35 it's i'm going
to sell this for 100 million and then if
you want when i've watched it i'm like
[ __ ] they were well on their way to
building something awesome but because
they [ __ ] put this outcome on a
pedestal they did this m a deal and then
they did this and it all kind of
unraveled so you know just even you
saying can it change already made me
feel a hell of a lot better like having
ambition is is an incredibly beautiful
kind of framework
sometimes people dig a little bit too
deep into numbers and it changes their
decision making and it hurts them so
keep going the number's so trivial for
us like i want to say a billion
it's kind of like the jets thing for me
like i will be very okay if i don't buy
the jets like beyond i'm okay now
forever for the rest of my life
the process of trying is the fun
dude we sell it for a hundred or
going keep going yeah the idea is that
like we see the home service base we see
the scalability um james dude said
something dinner last night about like
not killing the golden news so we can't
just pull out of home service
getting into cannabis real big they
can't send they can't [ __ ] advertise
online they can't do anything we're
doing huge stuff with mail with them and
make sense practices make sense
qr code straight to make sense
aggregating lists all that type of [ __ ]
smart also full-time agencies really
love because we're not threatened you
know of course you're the back end
exactly
we were we were debating with like do we
do a white label or not and conor the
rational one in the relationship was
like dude it's [ __ ] the ads we're
like the agency vanderbilt isn't going
to want to have their clients get an
invoice from dope right
when you get the [ __ ] english from
when you're on facebook ads yeah of
course it works the ad spender yep so as
we look towards this acquisition
whatever that number is you know it's
easy to set a metric of 40 being a goal
or whatever okay
as we build towards that path what would
your advice be about a focus as like so
we tie in with crms um send dave the
roofer to a job get a job crew 50
postcards or the neighbor we've got your
neighbor approved mark the job scheduled
another 50 plus cards going part of the
dose part of the noise and it works for
every [ __ ] particle so what we say
internally if it's timeless we spend
time on it surrounds us covered wagons
we want something to do with it so the
idea is like or my question first one is
where would you focus time is it all of
them is it one of them directly would
you you mean the service industries yeah
maybe you know service industries you
look at relatives about 70 or on labor
your equipment or something yes swing
relative conversation
cannabis
i say
my my intuition in this scenario off of
what i'm reading the answer would be all
of them but it would require you to be
less profitable each year
well what james knows
um is
vayner made no money for three years in
a row
most people
don't have that appetite which is why
they can't build big companies
then go to every vertical just hire more
people and make no money
yeah it becomes it becomes it becomes a
game of hey are we you know i don't know
what you're doing with the profits the
company's an llc wrong yeah right so
like you're gonna get taxed on that and
you're gonna like you're distributing to
yourselves at the end of the year
distribute less so you can be in more
verticals fast
great
so then it's so then it just maximize
your profits to reinvest in people so
that you could have heads and verticals
and go hard at every vertical that you
see opportunity in what do you see in
the canada space as far as the
opportunity i think it's gonna be one of
the top 10 consumer products in our
society
i think while facebook and google are
giving you an opportunity for land grab
you should go as hard as [ __ ]
possible because in about 40 minutes
it's not going to and you'll lose 80 of
your market
you know what i mean i think i think for
that one specifically because it's so
unique out of everything we're talking
about you should go incredibly hard
how would you push agencies
agencies are easy we have a lot of
agents
that's why you already have they're the
easiest yeah they don't want to do [ __ ]
they want you to do all the work and
they want to take a skim off the top
they're the easiest
that's
yeah like like you know this agencies
are thrilled to be a toll booth do
nothing
have you know make a margin on top of
what you do and call it a day there you
should get all of that would you like
for those big ones the little ones
little ones are easier i think because
big ones can have politics and like
are dopey
would you take their leverage so like
chris we love chris yeah right yes i was
like i could change your life chris
would you do that for me i promise like
they come with that ego [ __ ] so yeah i
would say i would say an unemotional
service provider
small demander go after the big ones
again this becomes a game of opportunity
like at your level like to me it's you
know i'm going through this with be
friends right now we have 29 people
we're gonna have 130 in september i'm
about to hire a hundred people
what's the best advice you can give to
someone
make as little money as possible if you
think you have a good business
the biggest mistake people make is
they want to take money from the
business instead of putting money into
the business now everyone has different
circumstances
you know some people have 400 000 in
debt and harder for that person to stay
chill than someone like so but the
longer you can hold your breath if you
have a good business and pour it back
into the business the bigger your
business is going to be so we debate
right now with funding we're pretty
liquid right now
do you take and carve out 10 equity to
use leverage with that are you just
borrowing money as opposed to taking in
funding
i think if the funding can be strategic
it can be very interesting right
right yeah which is really sometimes
hard to tell up front there's a lot of
trickiness to that but if you're when
you say you're liquid
to me
if you decide to take the concept that
we're talking about and hire a lot more
all of a sudden having more cash at your
disposal is pretty interesting i think
credit lines are interesting we forget
about that nerdy simple thing called
credit lines
you know i think i think
but i do think funding at times can work
i think money is the commodity for a
good operator i think
finding someone who's strategic who can
get you more business is interesting
example if a family
owned a private business of the biggest
service provider
like that's where you want to go because
immediately once they invest in you
they're also going to give you all the
clients and it's almost like you get a
double bite at the apple yeah so look
for that kind of person any verticals
that we're missing if you had your head
on this that you would be looking at
so this is direct mail automated direct
mail no minimum
that's really cool um influencers
i think if you educate influencers
through tick tock ads that
it's almost like the ad is really funny
it's like hey i know this is gonna sound
crazy you know what i mean like i know
this is gonna sound insane if you're an
influencer but running
direct mail in your no local area for
like pop-ups or events like it just
might become ironic enough when i hear
no minimum everyone should almost try it
i would i also think that people don't
like direct mail
in a world where ios 14.5 has changed
has more leverage than it used to i say
and so yeah i mean ecom already does it
i assume you're already yeah i think the
weird ones are influencer for sure i
think it's a weird one i think most
influencers will struggle with it but if
you get momentum what's cool about
influencers is that world is small if
god forbid emma chamberlain doesn't it
works for her coffee like all of a
sudden everyone's doing it and they can
get real big real fast
that's the one that probably stands out
as like a weird one
yeah and i think in your business if
you're running on the kind of margin
that you should be on a sas model you
should be doing like trial low-cost
stuff like it's just worth it for
acquisition
especially for your own learning oh yeah
every curious segmentation just give
people free executions
occasionally once in a blue moon i'll
definitely look at it all right
appreciate it
so tell you a quick story please yeah so
i was sitting on the cops next to joey
watching we wrecked
i don't know if you ever think of that
so i've seen this guy gives um
the founder of the company 4.2 billion
dollars before seeing the financials and
he gets called over and so we're sitting
here washing this up i'm playing holes
on my phone holds high up you're this
little guy and you're eating you get
bigger and bigger bigger and you have to
eat your competition i'm playing holes
and watching half-assed watching this
show with her
and
this guy gets called
to japan when when the japanese investor
figures out how much money he's
submerging a day
inside a beer right and so
he gets him over there he says who wins
in a fight the smart guy or the crazy
guy
and um the
the letter says well the smart guy and
the visionary like this jackal smile he
looks up and he says crazy
and the japanese investor spends around
he looks at him and and right when he
does that i eat my last competitor and
success first
and so i get the success first message
and he turns around and he says
you're not being crazy enough my son
do you understand
and i paused the show i was like [ __ ]
instead i was trying to go like let me
just tell you what just happened in my
head because you know when we were here
last time
um we were around three and a half
million in annual sales for a small car
dealership doing 25 to 35 cars a month
and
just over the course of of trying to
find my way and do whatever it doesn't
really matter
i started to be pretty bold like we we
pulled money out of other investments we
created a floor plan company to fund our
own inventory so joy now runs the bank
that supplies our personal money into
the dealership yep
we're turning up 25 return on that
investment
we um made second just yesterday our
reinsurance company was fully formulated
and now every car reinsurance has become
part of it we'll borrow money we're
creating a cycle this spin right
um
and i
it just clicked when i watched it i
shared that story because i i got to
like i realized that even though i'm
strategically making moves i quit being
bold
and i and i and just like we went in the
business and it's like can you sell a
car yeah we're selling cars and can you
make a profit okay now we're making a
little bit of a profit now profit's
growing and we're growing so we acquired
connecting real estate oh we went a
little bit longer and just because it
made sense we bought a 25-year service
that was next door and so we
really would this year we'll you know
three and a half years since i saw you
last time this year we'll do 15 million
it's amazing um
but i it clicked that the culture of our
place was has become really wonderful
our our staff you know we're
talking with claude earlier our staff
has heart it's awesome and and
everybody's on board for the mission and
the people that have weaved themselves
out make sense i'm going somewhere with
it go ahead i'm following you
so
like the next day i i get
um a guy who messages me and says hey
you want to take a look at our picture
like it helps your cars digitally look
like uh you know so we like within three
days i'm like [ __ ] yeah go 50 grand for
a photo booth spins around the cars like
it's going to make our digital presence
look better
um
let's do a remodel of the physical
facility we're bringing contractors and
it's just like i want to grow
aggressively in this thought across my
head was why can't i be the largest
independent dealer in the midwest
and and quickly like in three years i
think why can't i be the largest
independent dealer in kansas city
missouri understood and and so then i
realized that i've been kind of holding
it back from a marketing standpoint
inside of the the digital spend where
all the big platforms were supposed to
be
i feel like i'm probably blowing six to
eight grand a month in google ads and
facebook marketing because i don't know
what i'm doing
and so
this conversation has been happening
do i hire a fractional cmo and build my
own internal team or do i hire
or do i go outside and like budget is
not an issue we're super lean
the
making a lot of money and similar to
what you said earlier
i'm just pouring back and i don't need
the money to live i get it we're beyond
that and so
it's like actually yeah so here's my
thought on that i believe the single
most important
uh
variable in business
is
the ability to market
and so like i would rather support a ceo
who
she or he
fully knows what marketing looks like at
this second than somebody who's able to
balance the checkbook
because like because hiring
a grown-up controller
bookkeeper or cfo is the commodity of
earth
hiring somebody that knows at this exact
second where the arbitrage is in digital
marketing
is the most valuable
so to answer your question
given how young you are where you are on
your ambitions i would want you to
hire
a fractional cmo
probably i'd rather you hire just a head
of marketing
full person
and build a crazy relationship with that
person because i think the more
time and effort you put into knowing it
the more the business will be successful
do i empower that person then to you
know
can one person drive that
take us from 15 to 50. like
that
because we've got this little it depends
on how much
money is involved in that question and
how talented the person
are
but a lot can happen right now in your
business because of tick tock we haven't
had a
viral loop of this scale like tick tock
in a long time it's been a long time
since organic facebook fan pages could
do what they're doing so
normally i'd be concerned about those
kind of numbers but because if you crush
the living [ __ ] out of tick tock things
could get very weird very fast and i
think you got another 12 to 24 months of
this kind of tick tock
i think you could do a lot
the thing i think that the thing on the
dealership level that's my concern is my
first thought was higher
i wasn't thinking cmo i was thinking
hire a marketing professional and i'm
running ads like
75 to 150 in the midwest
and
no applicants you know there's a stigma
around used car dealerships especially i
think independent used car dealerships
and used car dealers to the conversation
and so
it's it's been very challenging when you
know
disenchanting i spent five to six grand
in a 60-day period driving ads to get
applicants and i was just to joy's like
[ __ ] it like let's just go to an agency
and say look
i've got a budget of 20 30
you know i think i think there's i think
it's interesting i mean it's really
funny to have the two people prior to
you be the people that spoke
it you know one could argue that the
combination of the two people right
there might be a worthwhile debate for
you when i hear five to six thousand
just to get a acquirer and and i'm
hearing fifteen thousand for coaching
like because you need to be the person
that knows it the best
you i i think the way i see it is how do
i get you to give me 90 minutes a day
and i promise you i waste 90 minutes a
day and i have five full-time admins
you definitely waste 90 minutes a day so
if i can get those 90 minutes and you
can go into full education mode of
understanding this stuff cold for a year
everything flows from there
the thing that has always made this
place tick is that these three
they know that i know it better than
they do
that is a wild
variable
that i highly recommend to all ceos and
leaders
when you are the best at your craft of
the thing you do there's something very
different that happens and most people
just become executives
and so i think the most important part
of your growth is your ability to market
you have a consumer product
yeah so you should learn that and and
where do you suggest that a person
begins in a coaching room yeah i mean i
don't have you know i can't you know
yeah obviously i think you should
definitely i mean i feel like that's a
little serendipitous you should have
that talk but i can't co-sign that i
don't know what's under the hood i also
think there's unlimited resources that
are free but i do think if you're
willing to spend that and that's for a
year that seems like something worth
debating and then and then
or if you don't like that kind of route
like you're like i'm not a coaching kind
of guy you can do it the way i did i did
it in the trenches and like just [ __ ]
learning by doing like like actually
doing though but like when you're
allocating 90 minutes to two hours a day
that's very different than what you're
doing now the only vote back in that for
me is just being
yeah transparent what it is is you start
talking to me about details and you
start talking to me about you know i get
in and i i see like i get in demand
facebook ads manager and it's like okay
campaign ads i just i get it
i get it i i would tell you that i'm not
the greatest interest and detail guy of
all time
it's just too important yeah that's fair
it's just the whole [ __ ] game here's
why
if i could get you to do it for just
even a year where you like really got it
ingrained you'd be able to judge the
person you're hiring the biggest reason
people are struggling with social media
is they don't know how to judge what
they're hiring you have no idea how to
judge it
right
you can't judge it right
that's true i can't judge you i'm not
telling you
i spoke last night
but i said if you don't understand it
you're not delegating you're advocating
right you're just completely you're
guessing yeah right you're guessing
that's how
you're guessing with real money yeah i
can't but but you can't also like i
can't go to a zero sum game while i'm
learning it either so i mean meaning bro
facebook blueprint just put that in
there facebook
hang on the [ __ ] for an hour a
day yeah yeah
you got 90 minutes oh these guys are
gonna they have no idea they're gonna be
marking around every person ever buys a
car for me again
that's gonna happen i get it yeah
yeah so i appreciate it thanks so much
i'd also really
it sounds like you have a great culture
i would have a company-wide meeting and
be like anybody here want to make
organic tick tocks for our company you
might get three or four people to say
yes just do that
just get that [ __ ] going
yeah just give free reign let everyone
sign into the tick tock account and go
make three four a day create a schedule
find somebody to coordinate go do you
care they're good or not
good of course i care but i care about i
don't care about us judging if it's good
let it hit the earth and see what the
world says people's hands who don't know
what they're doing
yeah because because because tick tock
is so unique in the fact that
we may not know and then it's the exact
right person so you got to like let it
roll do you
remember what they saw
sure sure but i think but i think i
think yeah but i think like
for example in this scenario i would for
everybody who raises their hand i would
let them have at least 30 pieces of
content in the system over a two three
four month period before you're like
karen's good johnny's bad rashaan's
awful susan's the best
you